Christopher Hitchens Weston
correspondent for the Nation magazine in
this morning's New York Times the
following quote from Mike Barnes
congressman from Maryland a liberal I
came down here very skeptical but I have
reluctantly come to the conclusion that
the invasion was justified u.s. citizens
were in danger or had a reasonable basis
to believe they were in danger because a
small group of hoodlums had taken over
this country that quote about it mr.
Barnes's trip to Grenada
your comment my comment is that that's
probably what most Americans think and I
think it's a mistaken view you have to
separate two things one is the safety of
Americans and the second thing is the
right to invade another country now even
if it could be proved that the American
students on the island were in danger
and that's very much disputed by
everybody and by the students themselves
that might for instance justify an
interview rate of the kind the
australias conducted in Uganda or desert
one of a kind that the United States
tried to conduct in Iran but in neither
of those cases was the objective of the
mission the overthrow of the government
in power in Uganda or Iran you might be
justified in going in and getting the
students out and there'd be no
difficulty doing that in a country the
size of Canada but it's perfectly
obvious that President Reagan's concern
was to overthrow the government of
Grenada and whether the students were in
danger or not that's what he wanted to
do christopher hitchens oh I think I
just so I can I would say one thing I
think it's a real shame that someone is
perceptive as Michael Barnes should have
been hoodwinked in this way were saying
mr. Hitchens for the last four years has
been with the Nation magazine been here
in Washington for the last two years he
has traveled to Grenada and Lebanon
within the last 18 months and among
other things besides working for the
nation here in this country
he works also writes for The Spectator
in London and as the foreign editor of
the New Statesman magazine also
published out of England writing a book
about the Cyprus crisis and
Middle East and as far as educational
background graduated from Lee school and
Cambridge also attended Oxford graduated
in philosophy politics and economics in
1970 married expecting his first child
originally from portsmouth hampshire in
england tell us some Before we jump into
all the septons this morning Christopher
about these publications
what is the nation well the nation is
the oldest weekly magazine in the United
States it was founded in 1865 by a group
of basically abolitionists anti-slavery
liberals and it's maintained a position
on the left of the spectrum ever since I
think one could say that of the
mainstream American weeklies we were the
most radical and as a result some say as
a result perhaps we have one of the
smaller circulations I think we probably
sell about 60,000 a week but we
certainly read by far more than that and
we know from our letters column we get a
lot of take-up who owns it nobody it
would probably be very cheap to buy but
you can't buy it it's kind of a trust
you know there's no proprietor so we
have there we have very little money in
exchange for me no money we do have
complete independence we don't have to
answer to anybody at the moment probably
our chief concern is foreign policy and
the the way that the United States under
President Reagan is taking a harder line
in the world and internationally and
it's of course we consider very
dangerous and I suppose your readers
would have guessed roughly our position
or my position from our very first
exchange about congressman Barnes let me
ask you about the New Republic how do
you follow the New Republic's or yes
what's the difference between the New
Republic liberalism and the nation
liberal well that's a very good question
I mean we've we used to be rather closer
together than we are now in the older
days when things were simpler and we
were both as it were associated with the
new deal with that kind of liberalism
the New Republic has gone a long way to
the right since then since Marty parrots
have bought it you can buy the New
Republic
he's moved it to the right on a whole
number of issues especially on foreign
policy and principally on the Middle
East they take a very very firm line in
defensive for whatever Israel should
decide to do and as a result in my
opinion their whole international
policies become more conservative
Christian there's a lot of news this
morning it's accessions there's more
analysis in our papers let's look at the
front pages in the New York Times
there's a story here by les Gelb who was
a former employee of the Carter
Administration the State Department
writes now foreign affairs for the New
York Times Schultz pushing a hard line
becomes key voice in crisis this is a
long piece on the front page I'm going
to turn inside here page 15 want to
quote to you something that's said in
this piece by the way do you have any
response to the headline in that story
have you had a chance to look at it I've
heard look at the story yeah do you
think mr. Schultz is in a stronger
position now than I used to be well it
struck me as an odd story for those of
you haven't read it it says that Schultz
is now arguing more and more as
Secretary of State for hardline policy
for boldness and intervention and so on
and that he's become a policy maker this
in response to a lot of stories that
have said that he's always being
overruled and particularly when Judge
Clark was national security adviser let
me read you a paragraph from this story
by les Gelb the common a common theme to
the response is recommended by mr.
Schultz this is what mr. Gale was saying
and approved by mr. Reagan has put
together from descriptions by officials
has been this this is the overall theme
that mr. Schultz is supposedly pushing
in the administration be tough even to
the point of using force if necessary
keep negotiation lines open but do not
be optimistic about positive results and
meanwhile solidify positions of strength
what do you think of that idea as a
method of going after foreign policy
well it may mean it like it sounds good
you know it sounds statesman like but it
actually it's just saying the obvious
it's what anyone would do what we what
we don't notice if that's what he really
means or if if the policy is he's
arguing for really conform to that what
I have a suspicion is that the sector
state is annoyed that in in the past on
foreign policy he's been rather left out
and the stronger personalities of the
president of ambassador Jean Kirkpatrick
and until recently of George Clark were
in a sense making policy without him or
at least making policy and then telling
him about it I guess as an attempt by
him to get back on board and it
obviously he's orchestrated it quite
well as far as the New York Times is
concerned you're from England originally
you know you write for the nation you
read our newspapers there's at least
like this in the New York Times I have
any influence oh sure
and by gell because he's thought to to
know what he's on about about State
Department matters what she does I don't
know if mr. mr. Schultz also helped to
write the piece of I slightly reads like
it I mean it certainly gives the Schultz
view of the world and puts in another
flattering way let me show you a piece
in this morning's Washington Post this
on page three you know media chose wrong
target and hitting subordinates for
black out now this is a piece by Luke
Kenan who has followed mr. Reagan for
years I used to write for Ritter
publications in California has been with
the Washington Post for at least the
last 10-15 years wrote a book called
Reagan and now he's talking about the
way the press was handled by the Reagan
White House during the Grenada crisis
let me read you a couple paragraphs and
get your response Reagan and company
believed that they won a pair of
glorious victories on the beaches of
Grenada two weeks ago by the way do you
think they did and in the sense that
were they successful in doing what they
wanted to do in Grenada I do think
anyone can deny was a successful
invasion I don't know how proud it makes
you feel to be able to knock out the
grenade normally but you certainly did
okay
the first was the defeat of the ragtag
Grenadian army and a band of armed Cuban
laborers the second was the rout of the
US media Reagan's advisers are convinced
that the media are virtually devoid of
public support in their protests at both
the news block out of the invasion and
the misleading statements made about it
you go mr. Kenan goes on to write the
advisers are probably right meaning the
Reagan advisors on the whole the news
media response has been less effective
than Cuban anti-aircraft fire and it has
been directed at secondary targets well
I think that's well put and I my sense
is as a journalist that that's true that
the public often thing that we're
spoiled and that we're too inclined to
snipe and criticize and
and Cavill which is our job and actually
you know you should be grateful that we
do it but I think there's a certain
satisfaction always to see us put down
and I think that Karen is right in
saying that when American troops are in
action people don't like the press you
know being too critical so they don't
mind that in effect the government
control the news about the initial
landing in Grenada I mean I think you
should mine I'm looking at you out there
I think that ought to matter to you but
my feeling is that probably there wasn't
much protest about it we read you
another Paris of final programs and mr.
cannons column in the Gibbon take a
political life before he was President
Reagan's good nature usually overcame
his suspicions talking about the
suspicions of the media acting in
conspiratorial ways but in the isolation
of the White House where his worst
inclination czar reinforced by the media
strategy of his advisors Reagan values
secrecy and lie detector tests and
regards even little leaks of information
as mortal sins the problem does not
begin with his subordinates what do you
think of mr. Reagan and that attitude
well he's not paranoid about the press
in the way that say President Nixon was
he doesn't hate the press he's quite
good at talking to people and you know
in many respects he's a nice guy and
gets on with with journalists but it's
true anyone who's president after awhile
begins to think the press has it in for
them and Reagan's no exception to that
the lie detector thing is a laugh of
course but there are the things where I
thought he was he was almost neurotic I
mean on the on the case of the briefing
gate papers the missing Carter papers
where he said you know the Pentagon
Papers were where the comparison not to
what the press was doing but to what he
was doing and comparing it to theft and
comparing himself to a theft or the
Pentagon Papers that struck me as as a
guy who really was beginning to feel you
know he was surrounded by enemies and
that that's an unhealthy attitude for
the president to have to the press I see
that everyone's a little busy this
morning on a Monday it's unusual all
lines except two from the West are
already lighted we'll go to the phone's
right now at area code 202 six to eight
to five to five in two oh two seven
eight three to seven to seven remember
if you've called us within the last
thirty days please hold off and let
others participate a sad note
for those of you who follow the
Washington Times or journalism famous
Washington reporter over the years and
editorial page editor of The Washington
Times has died of cancer and Crutcher 64
years old she was a guest here on this
program within the last six months and
what worked for years for the Washington
star has been with The Washington Times
since its beginning a couple of years
ago let's and Crutcher dead at 64 of
cancer editorial page editor of The
Washington Times on the front page of
the Washington Aria the USA Today Carter
Ford keep our cool this is from a
meeting that was held under the auspices
of former President Jimmy Carter down at
Emory University and the consensus on
the part of the two former presidents in
Lebanon we got to keep our cool don't
retaliate and hope for negotiations
quick response from you and we got a
phone call waiting okay well again you
know that sounds like good advice but
you're gonna have to decide in Lebanon I
mean there is no point in having the
army there if it isn't going to fight
and if it is going to fight you better
know who you're fighting for and that's
the Lebanese Falange party which I don't
think is a very good choice of ally
Schofield Wisconsin good morning you're
on with Kristen you're good so here's
mine
fine we don't have to get a morning
paper around here matter of fact I quit
the paper altogether what's that what's
on your minds morning I just like this
gentleman ah how you would like and I
would like to see the Russians take over
this country and see how they would
report under the Russians former
government they seem to tear this
government all to hell and shredded all
the pieces on the renew uh littlest
things I can't buy that it's constantly
constantly I was World War two veteran
if I wouldn't want one of them guys sit
and go outside of me of the fire sore of
the plane okay to face all the way
through alright let's see yeah what mr.
Hitchens has to say well I missed the
Second World War so I can't really
comment on that but I think most of the
people I've talked to who were in it and
have no complaints about the way it was
reported and didn't mind sharing
foxholes with
not a very brave journalists and
photographers many of whom gave their
lives to report the news and if you
think that the photograph of the Marine
Corps raising the flag on Iwo Jima is
good enough photograph for the arlington
monument to the Marine Corps then I
think it's probably good enough for me
that's on that on as to the Russians
taking over the country well their
attitude to the press is the same as
your seems to be which is that the less
of it the better I don't know if that
irony has occurred to you you don't seem
to be on other things very pro-russian
what do you read the treaty reports that
mr. Aaron drop-off has been out of
public eye for some time I say sit could
be very sick yeah well today being the
anniversary of the Russian Revolution is
the big the big day and said you know
for him to miss that parade must mean
he's ill Tempe Arizona
good morning go ahead please morning
Brian lamb and mr. Christopher Hitchins
okay yeah yes morning I'm glad to talk
to somebody from England you do make
sense to me you are dialog is true and I
will plant a fire in a minute here and
then hope you'll answer a question of
mine as a philosopher a seeker the truth
you talk about the Republic as the
liberalism and the house as liberalism
as the as the ruling factors of these
elected officials who are in conflict
okay over here in America in the United
States of America we have the ultra
liberals and the conservatives okay
which are and which in conflict so
therefore I am a conservative so high
image in a sense of troublemaker to them
who want their thing and I like to have
my freedom and that communist tile or
Marxist style or dielectric materialism
which is a separation of God which is I
believe in God as a spirit in a positive
way these people say no they are God
themselves okay
so therefore as I am a conservative
which is in opposition to the Liberals
than they are materialists okay so their
dialogue and their language do not make
sense to me
okay so therefore I am a philosopher and
a Sikh of the truth and when you
have the truth on your side then I
cannot agree to a wrong all right you
have any questions for mr. Hitchens okay
now you know the PLO you read the
magazine's I get the newspapers here
that the Tempe Kelly news and the
Arizona Republic and the Mesa Tribune
okay they are in conflict they're saying
one thing here and and another and you
have pictures and magazine these are a
way of knowing how the Conservatives the
Liberals and Inbetweeners okay and if
you're in between then you're not
knowing what side you're on that as you
you appear to be as a person who is more
of a conservative are you well I really
haven't been doing my job in that case
no no I'm not a conservative and nor is
the Nation magazine a conservative
magazine I mean you couldn't give ask me
very easy and a very difficult question
no I'm not I can't think how you've got
the impression we define ourselves as a
liberal radical magazine and I I think I
said at the beginning we're probably of
the available magazines in the United
States the most the most radical in the
mainstream very difference in American
politics between liberals and
conservatives well since we began with
Michael Bonds I'd say this morning the
gap was narrowing if Michael Barnes can
fall in behind Reagan's invasion of
Grenada then then liberals are getting
mushy all the time calls standing by at
Oak Ridge Tennessee good morning with an
NPV rate we took over
my understanding was whatever
establishment was wrong we're right
here's the front page by the way of the
New York Times this morning a hundred
bodies are reported found their training
camp in Grenada US official says former
premier is presumed to be one of the
victims found on the island you can
respond both for this story and to the
yes position of the lady from Oak Ridge
it's a very good question from Oak Ridge
I mean it's a good criticism of my
position but I'll still stick to it you
see in the cases I mentioned Iran and
Uganda the Entebbe raid and the desert
one rate to rescue hostages in both
cases in both those cases the
governments of the two countries
concerned were a chaotic barely
government's at all and be to the extent
they were governments extremely
unpleasant him in general I mean and the
Ayatollah Khomeini would belong in any
kind of central casting of rogues
nonetheless it doesn't give the United
States the right to appoint governments
for those countries in fact the reason
you have the Ayatollah is because the
United States for so long did believe
that it had a big sayin who should go in
Iran now in Grenada it's true there was
a horrendous massacre of the of the
existing government including Maurice
Bishop who was the prime minister who
I'd met and interviewed several times
and rather at night in many ways so you
won't find me defending with a grenade
in government over that day but I'm
still sticking to my point it isn't up
to United States to decide who runs
Grenada Long Beach California good
morning you're on with Christopher
Hitchens in the Nation magazine thank
you go ahead Oh Brian yes my compliments
to see fantasy fans I think that perhaps
the the nation in the world would be
well served if all journalists
correspondents and media were impartial
objective cetera as it seemed to be
thank you I appreciate watching c-span
very much
to get that 40 he's very upfront about
being liberal I appreciate these the
fact that he is upfront about that I'll
be upfront - I'm a conservative my
questions to him is what does he
perceive to be the government in Grenada
will be overthrew if in fact we did
overthrow a government that's it yeah
you may have been dialing your call when
I was talking to the last questioner
because I but I'll try and rephrase it
for you um I knew Maurice Bishop
interviewed him several times
quite admired him I had no time at all
for the what looked in the short time it
was in power to be a very gruesome
military despotism that overthrew him
but what I had gone on to say to the
lady from Oak Ridge I think it was
Tennessee was that I stick to my initial
point that that that does not give the
United States government the right to
intervene let me go back while waiting
for a next call and ask you again about
the difference between being a
conservative and being a liberal yes
another by all means but let me add
something that's that I should have
mentioned before everyone's now saying
how sorry they often Morris Bishop and
you know how terrible the government was
that overthrew him but when once Bishop
was alive and in power the United States
government did everything it could to
make life tough him they had an economic
boycott of Grenada they were denouncing
him for trying to build an airport to
increase the country's access to tourism
and to export-import markets saying that
was a military airport which was not the
case when he came to Washington he could
hardly get the time of day from anyone
so it's a bit late to suddenly say oh
what a shame he was overthrown by this
brutal group they were caught where is
this Rahway new dog yes I've been
watching a program for the last couple
weeks
ever since the eur/usd invaded banana
and my question to you and hisself
transmen is on the program before and
now someone mr. Lincoln and different
conscience into the states and they are
without they were supported
administration for invading cañada
my
questions you and and and to the
moderator this program is why is it that
each one of the law congressman speaks
about the ministrations have a right to
go in because to issue the democracy and
bring back really hell her free election
to be held why is it that no no no the
press have mentioned and including New
York time which I read quite often me
that Chris the ministration have not
demand free election in in South Africa
why is the death none of these are
Carla's all across the country that is
ill business in this country and not
concerned about democracy and just in
Vanara but not not democracy in South
Africa democracy in Haiti democracy and
in the Philippines why is that we have a
lot sided foreign policy on one hand we
want to see that we're so concerned
about the bishop administration I can't
think about and you notice and keeping
and in the in the White House noticed
the Commish notice now they also
concerned about the bishop that murder
and uh and they want to go in behind key
the right for democracy the President
Reagan need excuse to raid country and
when the bishop got murdered that was
excused to go in to overthrow the
government now you know it is the
moderators program notice and the
Congress notice and everyone everyone in
the free society notice but mine
basically concern is with the press they
did not have made a comparison on South
ethical and democracy and democracy in
Grenada our democracy and and and uh in
Haiti
where's all the democracy re-election
gonna be held and they are they are so
so concerned about in Nicaragua low I
think what sort of thing about in your
art and genera and theirs they are not
conservative in South Africa now all
right sure I think you made your point
go ahead Christopher well listen I I
agree with you I think that's quite true
I think all foreign policies are
obviously gonna be hypocritical you know
whoever's in power and whatever
government of whatever state were
talking about they're gonna be
ambiguities and inconsistencies but
there seems to be an enormous one in the
case of this administration that it is
only interested in here
rights when or if they can be argued to
be threatened by communism or communist
surrogate that is the only time it will
sound the alarm for human rights I think
that's a bad foreign policy I think it's
a nun American foreign policy in the
sense that I think America has an
interest in human rights everywhere and
the commitment to them or should have
and I think it's a dangerous foreign
policy to because it simply divides the
world into good powers and evil powers
and suggests that they'll have to be a
final reckoning with evil and a final
reckoning with evil in this case
everybody knows it and you can see it
coming down the road
is a nuclear war and nobody needs to
tell you what what that would mean or
the war that it would be worse than any
conceivable tyranny so that's my comment
to you I think you'll mention of South
Africa is very timely I mean even as we
speak the South African government is
designing a permanent system of
apartheid and trying to get only the
white voters to ratify it with some
signs of success and not a squeak of
protest from the administration about it
I think that that that is a disgrace in
ought to worry people Christopher
Hitchens has been the Washington
correspondent for the Nation magazine
for the last two years been with the
nation for the last four years and
writes for a number of British
publications we'll talk about a little
later let's go back to the phones to
Roberto California good morning thank
you nice to hear from you could I ask
you a question about the press at this
moment give us a give us just a
thumbnail sketch of what you think the
press ought to do as an institution what
do you want them to do for you well one
thing I consider there's an echo chamber
and my name is favor here the press
Enterprise we had just one wire service
they take the AP so you know you just
get an echo you don't I don't feel that
I get anything that isn't biased at this
bit isn't at times irresponsible I
it's time that the publishers and the
editors recognize this and somehow get
together and they're going to have to
read organize their their methods of
reporting do you ever go out and want to
buy something that is biased so that
will either support or be the antithesis
of your own view what the only thing you
can do is drop by eight or ten different
things and then try to put them all
together and I think we should have two
or three reliable places to go that if
the journalist Duvall does anything
that's against the national security
that they can receive death could you
tell me about that please thank you
I didn't I didn't understand what you
said at the very end they can receive
death yes no we've abolished the death
penalty in Britain though as a matter of
fact it is in reserve for acts of high
treason by doing this would be covered
by what you're talking about it is true
that in Britain there's an extremely
severe law called the Official Secrets
Act which says that anything the
government defines as a secret is a
secret it's a catch-22 law I mean you
can define something that is well known
by everybody as a secret under that law
and convict somebody for telling it our
American journalist freer in Venice
channel journalist in house well because
you have a constitution to see my
country doesn't have a constitution the
united states constitution specifically
enjoined congress from making any law to
restrict the freedom of the press or
freedom of speech or freedom of
expression so your First Amendment is a
tremendous guarantee that you can be
told the truth that doesn't mean the
press only tells the truth and I'm very
sorry that you don't take the trouble
either to go to the library if you don't
want to buy a lot of papers because I
know they're expensive but at least
perhaps to buy one national newspaper a
week I mean say The Wall Street Journal
which has an extremely good news
coverage or the New York Times or The
Washington Post
I think you really owe it to yourself to
to get more than one newspaper
Christopher Hitchens
let's go to Cambridge Maryland good
morning good morning good morning thank
you very much
mr. Hitchens I have three direct
questions short questions for you please
do you feel that Israel has a right to
exist within secure borders do you feel
that the United States should intervene
should Iran and/or Russia try to close
the Straits of Hormuz and would you seek
relief from a 24-hour shoot on sight
curfew from any quarter in which relief
might be found thank you
all right thanks for the call very good
questions and I think I know what you're
trying to pin me down on on the first
yes I do but I think the securely
recognized borders should not allow for
Israeli colonization or occupation of
the territory of its neighbors which is
what it's doing now the right to exist
argument has been has been used now to
the point where what it's going to mean
is that the Israel you're talking about
will include the ADI annexed and
illegally occupied West Bank so the
right to exist argument it's going to
rebound on those who use it unclear Lee
and who don't say what they mean by
Israel it's very interesting the Israeli
government has never said where it
thinks the ball is Israel really ought
to be and what it would settle for I
think would be an immense help if
Israel's going to insist on the right to
exist if it tells us where it thinks
Israel's boundaries should be every
other country does do that excuse me the
on the front page of USA Today it says
one in four of us will get a cold this
month and I think that today was my turn
the Straits of Hormuz look they're
international and vital and no attempt
to close them could be countenanced by
the international community when you say
what should the United States do you
already put the question in a in a
narrower way the United States would
have the same right as every other
country to be concerned about closure
and international shipping lane for
24-hour curfew well let's just turn it
round on you suppose that you
in a part of the United States that one
day unhappily perhaps because of rioting
had to have a 24-hour curfew and suppose
that you lived in a part of Miami which
is I think the last place that was a
curfew that I can think of where most of
the population was foreign say Haitian
do you think the government of Haiti has
the right to land troops to safeguard
patients if you think it has the right
to do that which you might think it did
do you think it has the right to change
the United States government while it's
about it all these arguments all these
arguments the 24-hour curfew the nature
of the government that replaced Bishop
the possible arguable very disputable
threat the students were under or are
all designed to evade this point does
the United States have the right to
choose the government of Grenada or does
it not Christopher Hitchens the Nation
magazine we go to Missoula Montana good
morning first of all I would like to
disagree with the comment mr. Hitchens
made that the fact that the runway being
built on Grenada was only going to be
for to expand tourist trade and export
import trade
I think it's obvious that that's not
true by the activities that were found
there and the amount of farms and all
the my main question is that the press
has been making an offer out of the
supposed operation yes when you look at
some press programs for instance the CBS
program 60 minutes if the press are
going to be so insistent no censorship
at all why shouldn't see CBS be required
to air the complete all of the complete
interviews that they take when they go
out to do a program like 60 minutes
instead of only clipping out the things
that show the the idea that they want to
get across why shouldn't they be
subjected to the same kind of lack of
censorship that they are crying so much
about now well I'll start with your
second point there's obviously a
difference between censorship and
editing I mean we
have an hour this morning daily tonight
we could obviously have be forced to
answer until we dropped I mean how many
people rang up all day you could make us
do that but it would be impossible to
actually know what we want to watch it
after a bit so you must distinguish
editing from from censorship censorship
is saying you cannot print something or
you'll be put in a position where it's
impossible for you to print something or
air something editing is deciding which
of the relevant bits obviously it's a
job that you've got it you can't really
trust anyone to do it I mean it's it's
putting somebody in a god-like position
but if somebody does have to the airport
you're just wrong about that it wasn't a
military airport and it would have been
very hard to adapt it into being one the
British firm that was building it plessy
large electronics firm in the United
Kingdom it's been quite definite about
it says that the specifications for the
airport were purely commercial the fact
that there were weapons found there is a
separate question I mean that the Kuban
workforce there was armed because it
believed that there might be the United
States invasion of Grenada everyone at
the time said how paranoid they were it
seems that the decision to have weapons
wasn't a stupid one Wellington Minnesota
good morning
I talked to your guests about the press
about the press being kept out of Canada
well they're not the only ones they kept
on carpenters bricklayers and doctors
and lawyers do you think the president
served himself well by keeping the press
out do you think the president made the
right political decision by keeping the
press out as he won that battle
political grenade did he win
by the way did he win I hope so there's
a hundred thousand people free today
if that makes any sense okay how about a
question for mr. Hitchens and see my
notes here then we have so many
journalists that call himself
journalists but aren't really very few
that I've heard on your program have
journalist degrees well I did one do you
think you should have a journalism
degree to be a journalist well they call
himself professionals you know a
bricklayer could be a journalism so
there isn't there's no absolutely no
reason why not in fact that's why I'm
I'm not particularly in favor of
journalism degrees actually in the
country I come from we don't we don't
have those but there's absolutely no
reason why a bricklayer if he's
interested in finding out I'm telling
the truth wouldn't make a good
journalist overnight it's been done by
the way when you say you've seen how
bricklayers on your mind a bit that
bricklayers were also kept out of
Grenada the fact is if you keep the
press out you don't need to keep out any
other Americans by keeping out the press
you keep the rest of America in the dark
automatically now if you really mean
that you don't want to be told what your
government is doing with your money
abroad then just don't turn on the news
but there are a lot of people who do
think that they ought to know and do
want to know what foreign policy is like
at the bayonet point and I don't see
what's illegitimate about that desire do
you Palm Springs California good morning
yes I'd like to ask your speaker there
oh if he'd known 24 hours or even 48
hours before the invasion of Grenada
would you kept in our press if you've
been asked to I'm just curious
I also have a second way you'd put press
sure you would you would have let them
know ahead of time where we're coming
they they knew it's you who didn't know
the grenades have known for a long time
that an invasion was coming Oh
idea sure they've been on the grins have
been on invasion alert almost
permanently for the last year I'll tell
you when when they really knew another
thing wasn't very well reported or
totally making people when the when when
the invasion was rehearsed which was
about a year ago long before the coup
long before long before the death of
Bishop there was a an amphibious
exercise in the Caribbean designed to
replicate an invasion of Grenada he said
earlier that you were a radical does
that mean that you sort of embraced the
socialist be a little bit more than much
level well when I was in the United
Kingdom I was a member of the Labour
Party which calls itself a Socialist
Party is a member of the socialist
international and I haven't resigned
that membership accepted in the formal
sense that I under longer carry a Labour
Party card so sure yeah Christopher
Hitchens what is your reaction when you
hear Americans say that their press is
liberal do you think that's an accurate
accounting of what the oppressors well I
think it's true to say that the press
and America is skeptical I mean in that
it considers part of its job to
challenge the government's view and I
think that's true certainly of the
Washington Post and of the New York
Times and of the Wall Street Journal
that they will not just take the
government's word for it politically
speaking there are great differences
between the three in the Wall Street
Journal there it's skeptical of the
government is very conservative
politically and takes basically the view
of the view of business the New York
Times and The Washington Post I think do
have a predominately liberal cast to
some of their reporting yes but
it's pretty mild New York City good
morning good morning morning yes I'd
like to talk to you
guests first of all I wanna thank you
for your programs I enjoy it and
obviously thank you guess the conference
stuff is a liberal radical which i think
is a new invention in the 30s 40s and
50s that wing of the Liberal Party were
called fellow travelers and the fellow
traveler is someone who's oh not a
communist himself promotes Soviet
political positions until they can
become mainstream well that's the intent
and their favor and very successful if
you can think of how the words have
changed very few people even call
communist communists in our common
Marxist radicals socialists now there's
a difference between a communist country
in a socialist country Sweden is a
socialist country Soviet Union China are
communist dictatorships they've done
that they've also made mainstream the
division between the Communists of the
free world they call it east-west this
is something you know here in the United
Nations they think it's just nothing to
do with the way of life and when he
talked about reporters world war two
reporters like Ernie Pyle we had a very
patriotic journalistic core at the time
and the reason for that is that the
Soviet Union at the time was forced to
join us because prior to the Soviets
entry into World War two we were being
sniped at just the way they do now but
because the Soviets we were in alliance
of the Soviet Union we had a total
dedicated core no one would think of
sniping at what we were doing
that's why the flag went up in Hiroshima
and it's been a patriotic symbol do you
ever read them nation collar funny do
you ever read mr. hitchens magazine the
nation
got ya the rag it's a rag rag how do you
define your own politics
I'm a Democrat I'm a Democrat and there
have been American anti-communist
liberals that's been a tradition we are
enlightened anti-communist we just know
that communism is a dictatorship and all
this young man has to do is talk to some
of my friends who've lived in the Soviet
Union and have been imprisoned for no
reason okay Romania or some of those
countries and to know that this is where
they should put their spotlight on
what's going on in those countries and
not compare all right thank you very
much for the call talk a little bit
about your you're your own personal
philosophy do you find yourself
sympathetic to a communist government
just start with that as a strong
question oh no I was going to start with
that actually the nation is I think the
only magazine in the country that has a
regular column called Soviet aqus which
is devoted to the study of the political
system of Eastern Europe is written by
Professor Steven Cohen of Princeton
who's a expert on the subject so much so
that the lady needn't worry his books
are indeed banned in the Soviet Union I
mean she's I can let let me reassure you
on that score there are no illusions
left about the nature of the Soviet
system and I don't believe the nation
can be accused of giving them any longer
life than anybody else
the thing about anti-communism is that
it can justify anything and that has
been the lesson of the anti-communist
liberalism preached by this lady when
she says that in the 50s our position my
position was known as fellow traveling
cold fellow traveling she should say by
whom it was caught that I mean and she
should say if she's nostalgic for a
period when Americans could be
politically individual ated and bullied
by Senator McCarthy if she wants that
she should say so and not just simply
say in those days that's what we were
called one of the nation's finest hours
in my opinion was opposing the witch
hunting policy of the senator and his
all sidekicks now my own position in
case I'm accused of concealing it let me
say it now this if I haven't said it
already I've already said I was a member
of the Labour Party in Britain the
Labour Party is a member of the
Socialist socialist international that's
the the family of socialist parties that
comprises from suomi torille the
Sandinista movement in Nicaragua and the
British Labour Party the Swedish
Socialist Party and many others I still
consider myself a member of that
political family and I don't feel that
coming out with it on the air as it were
a confession it's just an affirmation if
I'd known you was so interested in my
private political views I'd have put
them near the top of the show
Christopher Hitchens of the make nations
magazine the Nation magazine he's
located here in Washington the
magazine's headquarter New York it's
headquartered in New York 60,000
circulation how biggest at 60,000 and
climbing can I say can I get away with
that
biggest off a very small time I mean on
the editorial side only about half a
dozen others most of Munir most of all
of them all of them but me in New York
yeah San Francisco good morning I was
watching Manila reporters last week with
a week before but he had under secretary
dam on there and one of the to ask him
about the interview or the meeting that
he had had with bishop in Washington
before all this happened and they had
asked him if the United States had asked
mr. Bishop about the the Cubans in in
Grenada and Mr Dan said they had never
talked about that and also there's one
thing I'd like to know which is a
comment that I don't hear anymore
did mr. Bishop asked the United States
for help maybe financial help to build
that runway that's about all I have to
ask all right what do you read out there
The Chronicle in the morning yeah no yet
yes right here what do they do this
morning with the news pictures of the
grenade coup leaders Arafat rebels
battle revolution last strongholds and
big telephone switch
FBI probe breach of Stanford computer
generals party defeated in Turkey us
says it's winning its war on the Mafia
and a proposal for interim government I
haven't read it yet because it's a
little dark out here okay thank you very
much for the call yes bishop did ask the
United States for help as far as we know
he certainly asked him to stop hindering
his other Appeals for aid to
organizations like the IMF and the World
Bank I don't know whether he asked to be
included in President Reagan's Caribbean
Basin initiative which did include block
grants for Caribbean islands but I
suspect that he may have done because
they taken great care to freeze the
granadan government out and Grenada you
see is a country of difficult to
describe from my visit there how poor it
is it really doesn't have an economy I
mean even if however much was socialist
you are there's nothing there to
nationalize I mean there just isn't
anything and they had one very very
small airport on the wrong side of the
island and on the wrong side of the
mountains from the capital and we're
trying to build it build it build a
better one um I think probably United
States aid for building the airport was
requested the odd thing is that the
United States says it's the government
of Venezuela and the oil fields of
Venezuela that were threatened by the
the airport it's and Georgia's and if
the Venezuelan government oddly enough
was contributing money to the project
perhaps not believing that it was
threatened by the other one somebody
wanted to get a copy or subscribe to the
nation where do they go oh they should
write 272 Fifth Avenue New York City New
York 1 0 0 1 1 and mentioned my name and
they'll treaty right at 72 fifth avenue
new york city new york city new york 111
111 exactly well when I say 10011 I can
I always have to worry but as if because
1 mm 1 1 okay we'll try to give that one
more time I'm going to jot it down in
case some new stands around the country
have it although it's hard to find it's
not a comment on your circulation
department it's probably a comment on
the state MP
war Minister Pennsylvania good morning
good sir how are you
all right what do you read I read just
my local papers from the stand point to
subscribe to any of the larger
newspapers what is your local paper my
local papers the daily intelligence and
basically it carries local news as well
as selected national interest rate
where's your city located what's what's
it close - okay thank you very much go
ahead with your comment i just like to
comment on the press issue many
journalists that I see today seem to
forget that even though free press is a
right there may be some priorities
within the rights of our own
constitution and that being self
preservation of our national interests
when you take a look at world past world
the history and the like even as recent
as default the Britons restricted their
press so severely that they did they
kept inland ships in the lake when when
journalists lose their credibility I
think in this country journalists have
lost their credibility based upon their
past performances the American people
are speaking out now and I just feel
that without no type of checks and
balances on the journalists they're
doing exactly what this gentleman's
doing here to bring a four hour news
agent over into the country okay report
all the faults okay but don't take a
deep enough look at the positive aspect
of what a Free Press really is I'm
getting fed up with this kind of
questioning actually I mean thirty miles
from north of Philadelphia as you are
how do you presume to know that the
American people are speaking out to the
extent that you do know or what extent
that you can speak for them you can only
know it through reading the reading of
Free Press and watching a free TV the
truth is that the papers are reporting
the fact that they're unpopular with the
administration and the column with which
David began Lou cannons column today
says he he admits it's true that public
opinion is probably on Reagan's side on
this one
but if you want your press to be treated
as the British treated their press in
the Falklands you're gonna end up not
knowing very much about what's going on
if that's what you want don't read the
papers but do not prevent me or anyone
else from reading them how do I know
it's by watching programs like c-span
where there is reaction and there is
comment and there is interaction between
the people it's certainly not by reading
tabloids and magazines such as yours
which has been so severely edited or
slanted how do you know that if you
don't read it I would never read it
because it's got no only from the simple
point that I know how an editor work
what do you all of us see very lucky you
didn't you don't need to be told
anything you don't need to read anything
you just know now not everyone is as
smart as you and give them a chance okay
let's go on to Campbell California but
Christopher Hitchens of the Nation
magazine go ahead please okay first I'd
like to say congratulations on this last
answer and I'd like to find out another
thing I do believe that the press hasn't
gone deep enough and Grenada but in one
sense I keep waiting to see an interview
with the students who were left they're
the ones that decided not to come back
and the reasons why how many were left
there are called you know I that's
something I still haven't found out I've
been waiting to find out but believe it
was a third who concerns would left
there what are your suspicions my
suspicions are they were left they
decided to stay there because they saw
no reason to come back are you surprised
about congressman Michael Barnes's
response after visiting Grenada did you
hear that I hope he said this morning in
the paper I guess he didn't say it to
the paper necessarily but he said that
he had changed his mind about the
invasion he is a liberal Democrat from
the suburbs here of Washington and I'm
trying to find the exact quote so I
don't misrepresent him but let me just
read let me find it so that I can read
it to you here he said I came down here
very skeptical but I have reluctantly
come to the conclusion that the invasion
was justified
what do you think I think our justifies
it's unfortunate though that anybody
from any country had to die to be the
justification I truly believe that the
whole problem was overblown and I think
there could have been other ways found
to solve the problem of us rushing in
there and killing people okay Justin
Hitchens well you've obviously tuned in
a little late so I don't want to bore
the people who have been watching all
the way through but I also want to
answer your question I have I already
said that I I think even if it could be
proved that all the students were in
danger that would only justify a rescue
of the students on the lines of the
Israeli action at Entebbe or the
attempted United States action in in
Iran it doesn't justify overthrowing the
government of Grenada even if it's a
repulsive one now as to the ones who
stayed behind we haven't discussed that
yet I don't know I went to that medical
school I took a great care to go when I
was in Grenada and talk to the students
there all of whom like Grenada and the
granadan soar indeed very nice people
understood that the government was
hostile to the United States but didn't
feel that hostility expressed in any way
towards themselves I wouldn't be at all
surprised that a lot of them wanted to
remain it's delightful I'm sorry why as
a school there in the first place well
it's there because I just for the moment
can't remember his name but there's a
very medical yeah a very devoted man
that's right who just thinks that there
are a lot of people who don't get into
medical school in the United States who
deserve a chance to practice medicine
and he's founded why he chose Grenada I
I simply don't know but it's its own
justification if you see the island it's
such a beautiful place decides a place
for second chance students I can't pay a
lot of money I think there's a few pain
establishment yes that's graduated can
they come back and practice medicine the
United States yes I believe they can yes
they can I mean the the deploy was given
there are recognized yeah that that's
it's interesting also because that's
more likely to mean that the students
are going to be conservatives I think
me those who haven't made into medical
school here but who wants a practice in
private medicine and good avenues to do
so are not likely to be on the left
shall we say Miami Florida good morning
you're on with Christopher Hitchens in
the Nation magazine
good morning it's not really a question
is I'm having a lot of troubles with the
attitude of the press in looking at this
whole situation in Grenada as only a
security problem and not looking at
themselves and saying why is the public
against us and why is there's a
president do this in a sense that in a
republic that we live in the freedoms
that we have carry responsibilities with
them and the responsibility is to look
at what we're doing and see whether or
not it affects the well-being and
welfare of other people and I think the
press at a time when we need unity to be
united and stand behind our president is
not the time for the press to come in
with their interpretations and try to
sway of the public whether it's their
intent or not that's what happens and I
think our Congress is just as guilty and
we need to in a situation like this let
happen what happens and then critique it
and there is your freedom of the press
this is really becoming the theme of the
day isn't it
so I'll let me go at it from one more
angle I don't know if you've if any of
you out there who've been taking the
line that this lady's just taken have
noticed the ironic position that you're
in but none of the discussion that we're
having none of the questions you're
putting to me all criticisms you're
making of the press could be made if the
press wasn't the way you don't believe
it ought to be that's to say able to
criticize able to report everything you
I don't think you know how lucky you are
I was told by an earlier caller from New
York a lady from New York to imagine
what life was like living and so you
know I don't actually have to imagine
that I have seen those countries and I
have been in other countries too where
there's no press freedom believe me your
system is better and everyone else in
the in the world
of envies the right of the United States
citizen to have a First Amendment
guaranteeing his or her right to know
and making it impossible illegal in fact
for the government to restrain freedom
of expression sir any other country in
the world has this kind of freedom we
have no no Phoenix Arizona good morning
I wonder why the media they don't
support the right of the Palestinian to
exist they always report that you have
Palestinian your Egyptian do you think
that our American press is biased toward
Israel we have to Israel twenty nine
billion dollars a year while American
people they need it much more you know
then to give it to Israel yeah we waste
it on Israel for their aggression and go
on and occupy you know more land and
killing more people and they grow in
them and that mr. Hutchins said you know
they have no borders they did not claim
their borders you know when they will be
safe when they're bored of next to New
York okay let me ask you Christopher
Hitchens about what we're hearing this
morning from the callers
it seems like there's a lot of
unhappiness about the press and the
media
yeah and coming from all different sides
why well I think I mean I don't think
it's it's mysterious and I think that
lukannon identifies it quite well I
think there is a very strong feeling
among Americans that when your own young
men are risking their lives that
everyone should close ranks and the
criticism is in some sense disloyal I
think that's very understandable and
very human feeling but I think it's
mistaken because it's precisely at those
moments when you need a very very clear
sense of what you're doing and you can
only arrive at such a clear sense by an
open debate so tough though it is for
the press I think it's got to stick to
its guns and I think
I have never met an American who wishes
he hadn't been told what was going on in
Vietnam even though they often dislike
what they were seeing you mustn't
confuse the message with the messenger
and I'm afraid that's what a lot of
people are doing here but I've no
difficulty seeing why they do it and
when in the sense you know sympathizing
but but finally disagreeing can I just
answer our Egyptian caller just a moment
I want to tell our audience that for the
last are there guests here on the
program has been Christopher Hitchens
the Nation magazine and mr. Hitchens has
quite a background in education from
England where he went to Lee school at
Cambridge and Oxford studied philosophy
politics and economics graduate in 1970
has been with the nation for four years
here in Washington for the last two
years the Washington correspondent our
first hour is up